foreign
in
Michigan do they rhyme that's pretty
cool what's up Jen and from Michigan
Hi how are you dancing like I've never
danced before ever
we'd be dancing in the snow here so oh
gross is it cold it's gross yeah it's
fun there's fun today so it's okay
[Music]
that's how you know you're living right
when you're like it's miserable but
their son so we're good yeah yeah gotta
look for the positive you don't have to
but it helps all right so what's up Jen
how can I help
um so my question is how do I learn how
to give more affirmation without feeling
fake
um
well a little backstory my husband and I
were your favorites for high school
sweethearts uh did y'all watch Dawson's
Creek I don't wanna wait no
no okay well good for you I always
wanted to have a high school sweetheart
it just didn't work out for me okay so
good for you
oh yeah so we've been together for 25
years we've been married for 18 this
year
um we have four kids we they're 10 12 14
and 16.
um we also have a bonus student right
now she's our exchange student from um
Italy so we have a very Full House
um
my husband he's one of like
the most energetic positive people
um his
love language is definitely affirmation
and mine is not so his being affirmation
he's very good at giving affirmation and
mine is acts of service so I'm not so
good at giving it
um
but two of the four kids that we have
got the affirmation love language and it
is very hard for me to give them the
affirmation I will be able to say it in
my head I'll tell them but I'm proud of
them in my head or you know that they
did a good job or but when I try to
actually get it out it just there's like
a disconnect for some reason I just
can't
say it without feeling like they're
gonna think I'm fake or
like it doesn't mean anything I don't
know
why does your body react negatively to
praise
I don't know
um
I want to challenge your language a
little bit
um okay
you've got to stop talking in terms of I
can't
or I feel
okay all four of your kids
are in Desperate Like Oxygen need of
affirmation
whether you think you've identified two
that need it and two that don't all four
of your kids and your husband and
contrary to what some dumb internet
survey might have told you you need it
too
but something about giving it and
receiving it makes your body feel
awkward or weird where does that come
from
definitely makes me cringe though when
somebody gives me information
why don't you think you're worthy of
affirmation
foreign
like and I'm just going to run through
some stuff do you think you're too good
for it you're like yeah I know I'm
incredible did your parents do such a
great job pumping you up that
um when you hear it you're like duh I
know that I'm the best in this room
or is it the op like what is it about
affirmation
it is the opposite for sure okay
what do you feel like you're gonna lose
when your 12 year old comes be-bopping
in and worked her butt off or his butt
off on something and did a good job and
maybe not even a great job but a good
job
what do you think you're gonna lose
what's the net loss by saying hey come
here for a minute
and grabbing them on both sides of the
face and saying I saw how hard you
worked on this
incredible
I'm so proud of you
every day I thank God that I get to be
your mom
it's awesome
now get out of here like when you when
you hear me run through that what do you
feel like you're gonna lose by doing
that
um
I I don't want to say it but I think
it's control
I think that I'm
of them
I don't know treating me like mom
instead of a friend maybe
if that makes sense but I don't know if
that makes sense
tell me more I think it does but tell me
more
um
like
oh let me go to an example so I I coach
volleyball and I have a practice plan
out and whenever the girls will
you know be like what can we do this if
it wasn't in my plan or wasn't my idea
it makes me feel like
not disrespected but one of those words
just like like I've lost control of I'm
no longer The Authority maybe I don't
like that word either but that's what
that you were
you are using Authority and positional
power and what I think is one of the
most disregarded and overused at the
same time words of our current ethos
which is I just want to be me as
authenticity
you're using those as ways to keep
people at arm's length from you what do
you think is going to happen if you
connect with somebody
did somebody leave you when you were a
kid
no did somebody hurt you when you were a
kid that was close to you
no what do you think you're gonna lose
because you're hedging your bets against
something
I really I really don't know
okay
I need you to hear me like super clear
you're a great mom and I can tell you
love your kids and I can tell there's
something stuck between you and that
relationship
and I'm saying this with all due respect
and love and care but those kids are
starving for it and your husband is too
and I promise you you are as well
and hiding behind it just has to be my
way just has to be the highway there is
something about being a coach and there
is something about being a parent and
having appropriate like you're not my
friend
but connectivity all let me put this way
all the research says is the more
connected a parent is as the children
are younger
the more autonomous and the more
risk-seeking they are as adults it's
counter-intuitive
the more we want our kids to grow up and
be really strong and adventurous and
just go to the college or skip college
and go open the business whatever we
have to over connect with them
and so I'm just going to tell you this
as lovely as I can you're gonna have to
get over it and you're going to have to
decide I've got to practice and do these
things and when it feels awkward feel
the awkward and do it anyway
and your kids are probably gonna be like
what happened to you and it may be that
you have to
um I know a couple who struggles with
talking to each other
um he's really annoying and she just
finds him annoying but she loves talking
but it just kind of comes up so they
just both take into writing down notes
in their phone
and they call them talk topics that they
can just talk about when they get
together and it's kind of like when you
first have your first or second kid and
you gotta start putting sex on the
calendar and it doesn't feel as sexy as
romantic but it's either not going to
happen or we're gonna put on the
calendar it's very similar and I would
start making a list every day on a note
card or in your app on your phone that
just says I will pull each kid aside and
have skin to skin contact and I'll look
them in the eye and tell them something
wonderful about them and you're not
making them weak and you're not making
them cowardly and more importantly
you're not diminishing your relational
or authority you're their mom they
already know that
how does that sound
good
I have thought that I do need to write
more notes because I can write it down
like I said I just can't get it out like
I say it in my head I just can't get it
out what did anybody ever tell you
you're good growing up
um I mean yeah my parents they they were
good if I know my parents aren't overly
um
affectionate they weren't when we were
younger
um
so I don't know if that's just something
that I
taken from that where you know I I think
there's something else and I again
here's what where it's cool it doesn't
matter you have to fix this you got to
get this one right
because I promise you because you the
fact that you're asking the question
tells me you feel that Gap too right
what about your husband
um has he ever said things like he
misses you or where are you
um yeah
yeah he's like I said he's
he's kinda
killed in for me with the kids yeah
don't let that's uh I'm throwing a flag
on that one and yeah
sometimes the inability to praise is the
exact same pathology is over praise
yeah and he may be reaching for stars to
try to get something he's not getting
in his own home
yeah
is that fair
I would love love love love love you to
sit down tonight and ride out here are
some things that I think are wonderful
about my kids
and make a plan and start telling them
even if you would make a public
announcement at dinner tonight that said
I'm gonna begin practicing I love each
of you so much and it's so crazy how
Wild I am about you guys and how proud I
am of you all
that I'm going to begin making sure you
all know it and it's going to be weird
because this isn't anything Mama's ever
done before but it's going to be new and
you're just gonna have to get over it
because I'm gonna tell you every day how
much I love you I'm gonna tell you every
day how much how proud I am of you
I'm gonna tell you every day that I saw
I caught you doing something right and
I'm gonna let you know about it and this
is you just practicing and then you look
at your husband dead in the eye and say
I realize that I under the guise of this
isn't my love language or whatever bull
crap that is
I have not given you the affirmation
that you need I'm sorry and I tell you
this uh here's what gen is important
when my marriage was on the brink
like hanging on by dental floss barely
I remember how embarrassed I was to tell
my wife I just want you to tell me that
you're proud of me
I worked so hard for you for this house
and I I'm ashamed to say that that would
give me that would be like water in the
desert but will you tell me and she told
her her response was man that would have
been awesome to know 20 years ago I
didn't know you needed that
I do I do
so make a commitment to him I'm gonna
say one nice thing in the morning I'm
gonna say one nice thing in the
afternoon I'm gonna ask him one question
about his day in the morning one
question in the afternoon
and it's also fair to say hey husband I
need this too here's what I need
but you got to do it no matter what and
how uncomfortable it is you got to
practice you got to practice you got to
practice this is something you got to
get right our kids need us
and your kids need you thank you so much
for the call Jen